it's red and pricey it's a critter and a
delicacy it's the creme de la creme of
seafood but this beloved summertime
favorite was once thought of as the poor
man's food
say what
it is said that in the early 16th
century as the first pilgrims began to
settle in bay areas of america that the
oceans overfloweth with lobster no
literally they overfloweth imagine a
shore with a lobster wall two feet tall
as one would expect the settlers ate
them up until like anything eaten three
times a day they got sick of them
eventually deeming them the cockroaches
of the sea
after that lobsters were used as
fertilizer fish bait and ultimately
prison food
they were fed so often to inmates that
there was even a law enacted to protect
said inmates from cruel and unusual
lobster punishment
so then how did lobster become the
succulent delicacy we all know and love
fast forward to the mid-1800s canned
food became a thing as did the railroad
lobsters were canned and shipped to
middle america at the same time middle
americans started traveling to new
england for fresh lobster by the late
1880s prices began to surge and by world
war ii lobsters became the pricey
specialty we've all grown to enjoy